I just want to talk about raising
children outside of what is considered
the norm because it's challenging Jada
pinkett-smith discussing gender norms
with EJ Johnson and his mom cookie on
her Facebook watch show read table talk
the read table is the place of testimony
you know and a place where we get to
share our story share our experiences
and get to really talk and spill our
truth in a very raw way the group
candidly disgusts EJ coming out and how
his father legendary NBA star Magic
Johnson reacted my husband is the calm
person like he reacts quickly mm-hmm so
everything that came to the top of his
head he just let it out according to
Jada will had a similar reaction when
son Jaden was asked to star in a 2016
women's fashion campaign and wear a
skirt will called me be Will Smith Will
Smith you know what I mean and he's like
nope this my son is not supposed to be
and I'm Louie Vuitton ad wearing skirts
that is not no no no no no no hold up is
this a good idea and I was like well you
know what will is what he wants yeah
this is this is his expression mm-hmm
and he said okay but the girls trip star
admitted that her two kids are
constantly educating her about gender
norms as Jaden and Willow have always
been different mm-hmm they were born
that way
[Applause]
[Music]